[Music]
there are movies with little to no
special effects
movies with a moderate amount movies
with a lot of them
and then there's zack snyder's justice
league
if you want to know what justice league
looked like before
all those effects were added here's a
peek behind the scenes
the first mother box steppenwolf comes
after is in possession of the amazons in
themyscira
in a heavily guarded temple it's the
first time we see the horned villain in
the film
and when he lands via a portal he has no
qualms about
slinging these women left and right as
they battle him without fear
queen hippolyta realizes she has to take
the mother box
out and seal the temple despite knowing
several of her fellow amazons will die
in the process
ashy escapes through a tunnel awaiting
amazon warriors stand by with large
hammers
ready to knock out massive stone pillars
which will release several walls and
trap all inside
hopefully killing steppenwolf in the
process in reality we know that these
amazons are just hitting large foam
pillars wrapped in green cloth
as this hbo max behind the scenes clip
reveals
in part two of the film diana prince
gives bruce wayne a five-minute lesson
on the golden age of heroes and their
battle against
darkseid while the audience is treated
to a visual montage of the whole shebang
we see atlanteans the old gods a green
lantern
amazons and men battle against darkseid
and his armada in an all-out war
bodies are flying all over the place in
this scene
as almost everyone except men can launch
themselves into the air with ease
there is one shot of an unknown amazon
who climbs on top of her horse before
jumping into the air to wreak havoc
on some parademons in a behind the
scenes clip we can see that her horse is
not real at all
and neither is the world around her when
steppenwolf comes for the second mother
box
he has to look for it in the ocean as
it's being guarded
underwater by atlanteans mira is one of
the first atlanteans to challenge
steppenwolf and fights him off as he
tries to steal the box
steppenwolf gets the upper hand and
almost wipes her out entirely
before aquaman shows up to save the day
yet again
an underwater fight sequence isn't easy
as this behind the scenes clip proves
three crew members had to help sling
jason mamowa around in the air as he
hung from wires
to make his movement look effortless as
if he was truly underwater
just before the team revives superman
they have to break into star labs
so they have the entire place evacuated
with false alarm put in place by cyborg
victor struts down one of the walkways
carrying a mother box when he passes his
father
dr silas stone silas is trying to alert
the evacuated staff that the alarm was
actually
false when he sees his son is up to
something and ends up going along with
the plan
in a behind the scenes clip it looks
like the scene was filmed without green
screens
as ray fisher dons his motion capture
suit
fitted with two red glowing lights and
walks down the corridor with his father
just behind him
doomsday decapitated superman's head
from his monument
in batman vs superman dawn of justice
and it was never reconstructed
the revived superman ends up using this
head as a weapon against the justice
league
but it's not as effective as he might
have hoped as he picks up the head with
ease
superman launches it directly at wonder
woman who slices it in half with her
sword like she's cutting a piece of cake
it's interesting to see in this
behind-the-scenes photo which henry
cavill posted to his instagram
that the green prop version still
resembled a head
later in the big showdown after he
blocks wonder woman's attack
superman pulls her arms apart and head
butts her
she fires one right back at him which
takes him a second to recover from
after he's had enough superman delivers
the headbutt
of all headbutts when he lifts himself
in the air and comes down on wonder
woman like a ton of bricks
in order to get this scene perfect a
green screen covered crew member
had to aid henry cavill by bending his
legs in a way which brought more
fluidity to his body
while he was held up with wires it would
have been impossible for cavill to bend
his body this way while up on the wires
so the silly looking crew member was
essential to get it just right
it turns out that one of the movie's key
outdoor scenes
was actually filmed outside if you can
believe it
after clark kent sees lois lane and is
reminded of who he is
the duo flies off to his family's
foreclosed farm
and spend some time in the field getting
reacquainted
while the white farmhouse was real the
massive tree and surrounding buildings
we see in the movie
aren't large green screens were used so
additional buildings could be added in
as well as a few oversized leafless
trees
we had seen these extra buildings before
in man of steel
where clark's father jonathan kent hid
his crashed kryptonian ship
after the boy first landed on earth
throughout zack snyder's justice league
we see bruce wayne
cyborg and alfred work on the flying fox
the jet bruce constructed as a troop
carrier the team had some issues getting
it to fly but eventually the jet is in
working order and carries the team
across the world to take on steppenwolf
bruce mans the flying fox alone after
dropping the team off on land
and takes down steppenwolf's force field
allowing everyone to enter and start
smashing skulls
while it looks like affleck really is in
some type of aircraft at the movie
he's actually sitting in a wooden
approximation of the ship's cockpit
that remains stationary and he has to
thrust himself around to make it look
like he's actually in motion
ah movie magic check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the snyder cuts are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you